let's say that we run a school and in
that school there is a population of
students right over here
that is our population and we want to
get a sense of how these students feel
about the quality of math instruction at
the school so we construct a survey and
we just need to decide who
are we going to get to actually answer
this survey
one option is to just go to every member
of the population but let's just say
it's a really large school let's say
we're we're college and there's 10 000
people in the college we say well we
can't just talk to everyone so instead
we say let's let's sample this
population to get an indication of how
the entire school feels so we are going
to sample it we're going to sample that
population
now in order that in order to avoid
having bias in our response in order for
it to have the best chance of it being
indicative of the entire population we
want our sample to be random so our
sample could either be random
random
or not random
not random
and it might seem at first pretty
straightforward to do a random sample
but when you actually get down to it
it's not always as straightforward as as
you would think
so one type of random sample is just a
simple random sample
so
simple
random
random sample
and this is saying all right
let me
maybe assign a number to every person in
the school maybe they already have a
student id number and i'm just going to
get a computer a random number generator
to generate the 100 people the 100
students so let's say there's a sample
of 100 students that i'm going to apply
the survey to so that would be a simple
random sample we are just going into
this whole population and randomly let
me just draw this so this is the
population we are just randomly picking
people out and we know it's random
because a random number generator or we
have a string of numbers or something
like that that is allowing us to pick
these students
now that's pretty good it's unlikely
that you're going to have bias from this
sample but there is some probability
that just by chance your random number
uh your random number generator just
happened to select maybe a
disproportionate number of boys over
girls or a disproportionate
number of freshmen or a disproportionate
number of engineering majors versus
english majors and that's a possibility
so
even though you're taking a simple
random sample and it's truly random once
again it's some probability that's not
indicative of the entire population
and so to mitigate that there are other
techniques at our disposal one technique
is a stratified sample
stratified
and so this is the idea of taking our
entire population and essentially
stratifying it so let's say we want to
we take that same population we take
that same population i'll draw it as a
square here just for convenience
and we're going to stratify it by
let's say we're concerned that we get an
appropriate sample of freshmen
sophomores juniors and seniors so we'll
stratify it by freshman
sophomores
juniors and seniors and then we sample
25 from each of these groups so these
are the stratifications this is freshman
sophomore
juniors
and seniors and instead of just sampling
100 out of the entire pool we sample 25
from
each of these
so
just like that and so that makes sure
that you are you are getting indicative
responses from
at least all of the different all of the
different grew all of the different age
groups or
or levels within your university
now there might be another issue where
you say well
i'm actually more concerned that we have
accurate representation of males and
females in the school and there's some
probability if i do 100 random people
it's very likely that it's close to 50
50 but there's some chance just due to
randomness that's disproportionately
male or disproportionately female and
that's even possible in the stratified
case and so what you might say is well
you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to there's a technique called
a clustered sample and let me write this
right over here clustered
a clustered sample
and what we do is we sample groups each
of those groups we feel confident has a
good balance of male females so for
example we might instead of instead of
sampling individuals from the entire
population we might say look you know in
on tuesdays and thursdays and this well
even there as you can tell this is not a
trivial thing to do we'll let's just say
that we can split our
let's say we can split our
population
into groups maybe these are classrooms
and each of these classrooms have an
even distribution of males and females
or pretty close to even distributions
and so what we do is we sample the
actual classrooms so that's why it's
called cluster or cluster technique or
clustered
random sample because we're going to
randomly sample our classrooms each of
which have a
close or maybe an exact balance of males
and females so we know that we're going
to get good representation but we are
still sampling we're sampling from the
clusters but then we're going to survey
every single person in each of these
clusters every single person in one of
these classrooms so again once again
these are all forms of random surveys or
random samples you have the simple
random sample you can stratify or you
can cluster and then randomly pick the
clusters and then survey everyone in
that cluster
now if these are all if these are all
random samples what are the non-random
things like
well one case of non-random you could
have a voluntary
voluntary
survey
or voluntary sample this might just be
you tell every student at the school hey
here's here's a web address if you're
interested come and fill out this survey
and that's likely to introduce bias
because you might have maybe the
students who really like the the math
instruction at their school more likely
to fill it out maybe the students who
really don't like it more more likely to
fill it out maybe it's just the kids who
have more time more likely to fill it
out so this has a good chance of of
introducing bias the students who fill
out the the survey are just might be
just more more skewed one way or the
other because just you know they
volunteered for it
another
non another not random sample it would
be called a
a can a
you're introducing bias because of
convenience is the term that's often
used and this might say well let's just
sample the hundred for students who show
up in school and that's just convenient
for me because i didn't have to do these
random numbers or do the stratification
or doing any of this clustering but you
can understand how this also would
introduce bias because the first 100
students who show up at school maybe
those are the most diligent students
maybe
they all take an early math class that
has a very good instructor or they're
all happy about it or it might go the
other way the instructor there isn't the
best one and so it might introduce bias
the other way so if you let people
volunteer or you just say oh let me go
to the first n students or you say hey
let me just talk to all the students
who happen to be in front of me right
now
they might be in front of you out of
convenience but they might not be a true
random sample
now there's other reasons why you might
introduce bias and it might not be
because of the sampling
you might introduce bias because of the
wording of your survey you can imagine a
survey that says
do you consider yourself lucky to get a
math education that very few other
people in the world have access to well
that might bias you to say well yeah i
guess i feel lucky well if the wording
was do you
do you like the fact that a
disproportionate more students at your
school
tend to fail uh algebra then a school
then our surrounding schools well that
might bias you negatively so the wording
really really really matters in surveys
and and there there's a lot that would
go into this and the other one is just
people's you know it's called response
bias and once again this isn't about
response
or response bias and this is just people
not wanting to tell the truth or maybe
not wanting to respond at all maybe
they're afraid that somehow their
response is going to show up with in
front of their math teacher or the
administrators or if they're too
negative it might be taken out on them
in some way and because of that they
might not be truthful and so they they
might be overly positive or not fill it
out at all
so anyway these are these are this is a
very high level overview of how you
could think about sampling you want to
go random because it lowers the
probability of their introducing some
bias into it and then these are some
techniques and also think about whether
you're falling into some of these
pitfalls that have a good chance of
introducing bias